for only the third time in 243 years a
US president has been impeached donald
trump's been charged with abuse of power
and obstruction of congress the vote
came following more than eight hours of
divisive debate in the Democrat
controlled House of Representatives she
Hobart Anzhi begins our coverage from
Washington DC the result was never in
doubt Donald Trump is the third US
president in history to be impeached
article one is adopted article two is
adopted gentleman from New York over
several hours the Democrats repeated
arguments that have now become very
familiar the president needs to be held
to account madam Speaker the House of
Representatives must now consider two
articles of impeachment against
President Trump
the first article charges that the
president used his public office to
coerce a foreign government into
attacking his political rival the second
article charges that the president took
extreme and unprecedented steps to
obstruct our investigation into his
conduct taken together the two articles
charged that President Trump placed his
private political interests above our
national security above our elections
and above our system of checks and
balances what we are discussing today is
the established fact that the president
violated the Constitution it is a matter
of fact that the president is an ongoing
threat to our national security and the
integrity of our elections the basis of
our democracy a central charge against
the president is that he was demanding
the Ukrainian government announced an
investigation into Joe Biden and his son
hunter in return for an official White
House visit and military aid however the
Republicans argue that the Democrats
have failed conclusively to prove that
case they say President Trump was right
to be concerned about corruption in
Ukraine in addition they argue that
hunter Biden's position on the board of
a Ukrainian energy company while his
father was taking the lead in Ukrainian
policy as vice president does warrant
further examination and they argue that
impeachment is simply an attempt to
overturn the results of the 2016
election we on the Republican side have
no problem
taking our case to the majority into the
people of this country because they
elected Donald Trump and it is a matter
for the voters not this house not in
this way not in the way this is being
done it is trampled everything this
house believes in our Democrat
colleagues have weaponized the
impeachment provision of the
Constitution to nullify the votes of 63
million Americans who elected president
Donald J Trump this is not about a phone
call or Ukraine or even his use of the
executive privilege you have to remember
that 95 of the Democrats on this floor
today voted to impeach Donald Trump
before the July 25th phone call ever
happened between President Trump and
President szalinski a trial is expected
to be held in the Senate in January the
Republican leadership is hoping for a
relatively quick process of perhaps two
weeks the president is almost certain to
be acquitted the poll suggests the US
public is evenly split on impeachment in
fact Donald Trump's approval ratings
have increased since impeachment
proceedings began in the autumn cher
Burton C al Jazeera Washington while the
vote was happening Donald Trump was
telling supporters that our rally in
Michigan that the impeachment was an
attempted coup through their depraved
actions today crazy Nancy Pelosi's House
Democrats
have branded themselves with an eternal
mark of shame in it it really is it's a
disgrace you are the ones interfering in
America's elections you are the one
subverting America's democracy we did
nothing wrong nothing whatsoever this
was just an excuse you are the ones
obstructing justice you are the ones
bringing pain and suffering to our
republic for your own selfish personal
political and partisan game we have
three correspondents across this story
at a moment we'll go to John Hendren at
the Trump rally in Michigan we have
White House correspondent Kimberly hawk
at first though we'll go to Heidi Joe
Castro who's on Capitol Hill some people
of course have been watching this
incessantly hour on our others are just
joining us so let's take a step back and
have a look here Heidi at what has taken
place and historic moment the
impeachment of a president take us
through it
absolutely Stan you know it's been two
months of this impeachment inquiry but
really it's been two plus years of this
partisan vitriol that's all climaxed at
these historic votes that we just saw
which formally impeaches president Trump
and we saw these votes on the two
articles of impeachment unfold almost
clearly and solely along partisan lines
all but four Democrats in the House of
Representatives voting to approve the
the impeachment of Trump
there was one independent who sided with
those Democrats in approving the
articles and then every single one of
the Republican members in the house
voted against the impeachment not a
surprise at all given all the partisan
arguments that we've seen unfold today
as well as through these last few weeks
and those arguments have been pretty
much the same a repetition Republicans
saying that this entire impeachment
process is illegitimate that Democrats
are pursuing it out of partisan distaste
for Trump and for his policies while
Democrats are framing this in historic
terms saying
that the founders of this country had
envisioned using this tool of
impeachment to hold those who who occupy
the highest offices in the land to
account when they betray their country
and they're saying Donald Trump did that
when he requested that Ukraine interfere
with the upcoming presidential elections
House Majority House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi spoke with reporters shortly
after these historic votes a great day
to the Constitution of the United States
a sad one for America that the
president's reckless activities
necessitated us are having to introduce
articles of impeachment so I do this
this day this vote is something that we
did to honor the vision of our founders
to establish a republic the sacrifice of
our men and women in uniform to defend
our democracy and that Republic and the
aspirations of our children that they
will always live in a democracy and that
we have tried to do everything we can to
make sure that that is their reality
Heidi now the process is that the
articles of impeachment go to the Senate
where there will be a trial that hasn't
happened yet take us through what the
the stages are from here that's right so
now House speaker Pelosi is set to
choose the impeachment managers these
are members of the house who will serve
essentially as the prosecutors in the
Senate trial but that zeroes in on a key
question that we still have unanswered
which is when is she going to make that
selection of the impeach managers and
when are they going to literally walk
across the Capitol and deliver these
articles to the Senate chamber which
would officially pass this into the next
stage of the impeachment well she was
asked that by reporters in this press
conference and she was very coy with her
answer she would not lay
a timeline and in fact said that she
would not make a decision until she's
convinced that the Senate will hold a
fair trial so that really leaves things
open and we are uncertain exactly when
this impeachment will proceed forward
how do you thank you for that well
Donald Trump has been rallying
supporters at Battle Creek in Michigan
for more than an hour now he's just
wrapped up that speech John Hendren is
there John what does he had to say well
the president was clearly energized by
this impeachment process and by the
crowd that was here in Battle Creek
Michigan he spoke for by my count a
little under two hours and about a third
of that according to his prepared
remarks anyway about a third of that was
on impeachment that you heard the the
quotes earlier where he said the
Democrats have branded themselves with a
mark of shame he said they are the ones
who were endangering democracy and he
gets energized by these crowds and he
continues on he was went a little more
than 30 minutes longer than he was
expected to speak and he was received of
course enthusiastically this was a crowd
of many thousands by one count about
18,000 some of them are waiting outside
along with a very small number of
protester the president was not at all
County offered no apologies
he was defiant and he made it clear that
he's going to seek reelection in 2020
and to do that he needs the help of
states like Michigan Michigan is one of
those states the swing states 3-1 by a
very narrow margin no Republican had
done that since George Herbert Walker
Bush in 1988 and Trump won with 47 point
three percent of the vote to Hillary
Clinton's 47% of the vote that's about
50,000 votes and that is about the
number who votes right here in this
county so he's in one of those places
that he needs to win in 2020 and by the
look of the crowd that is here he
certainly got a lot of supporters here
John thank you for that John Hendren
there at that Trump rally Kimberly
halket is at the White House Kimberly
this is the third president now to be
peached but the difference here is he is
going to seek re-election the question I
suppose out of all of this is how this
is going to play politically what's your
assessment yeah this is the real we're
in uncharted territory as we've said so
many times with this present and and
this presidency and the fact that voters
will ultimately have the ability to
weigh in on whether or not the Congress
acted appropriately is certainly
remarkable Donald Trump has already
commented on the fact that he believes
that this has helped his poll numbers
that they have gone up particularly in
battleground states I think it's also
important to note here that Donald Trump
has essentially as a master marketer
he's taken what most people would see as
a very devastating moment and already
he's shining it up and packaging it as
something that's not hurting him but is
hurting the opposition Democrats
essentially he made the argument that
they are and they have the stain on
their sort of legacy not him
even though this is of course a historic
moment for the president and that he's
going into the history books as the
third president to be impeached
this is the sort of trademark defiance
of Donald Trump and well it is a very
somber moment we're also seeing his
White House team also in working in
concert rebranding all of this as we saw
the Democrats like House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi talking about this very somber
moment the press secretary was tweeting
out the moment where after the first
article of impeachment Democrats cheered
these are the kinds of moments in those
contrasts that Donald Trump supporters
seize upon and I think was really
notable as the president was talking
there was somebody wearing a t-shirt
that said keep Trump impeached Congress
very quickly he was elected to be the
disrupter in chief in Washington he kept
that promise and he wants to do it again
you were certainly saying that Kim
believed thank you so much for that
Kimberly halket from the White House